ethiopians are voting in national
elections on monday it's a day of
reckoning for prime minister abby ahmed
as he hopes to boost his legitimacy
with the vote at his first and last
campaign rally this week he said his
main goal was to uphold what he called
the unity and freedom of the country
the election is taking place against a
backdrop of tensions
now let's quickly take a look at how we
got here in 2018 i'll be
road to power on a wave of optimism
after three decades of oppressive role
dominated by the
tigran people's liberation forces or
tplf
a party anchored in the northern region
now after taking office abby made peace
with neighbouring eritrea bringing an
end to a 20-year conflict but that move
earned him
the prestigious nobel peace prize but it
also angered the tplf forces
who neighbor eritrea then last year
abi sent the army into the northern
tegrad region to crush the tplf
thousands have been killed and millions
displaced
to make matters worse ethnic violence
has flared elsewhere hundreds have died
in
clashes on the border between oromia and
amhara the country's two most popular
states
critics accuse abby of denying states
with different ethnicities
more autonomy it's led some opposition
figures
to boycott the poll now we will be
discussing what is at stake for ethiopia
but first we turn to the prime
minister's home region in oromia to find
out what voters there
make of the man
a rally in favor of abi ahmed's
prosperity party
close to his hometown in the aromia
region it was here that crowds of young
people went out on the streets in 2018
to support abi
in this district many still do
based on the work he has achieved we
believe that the prosperity party can
transform this country
the work he did until now shows that he
can bring a lot of things for our future
we believe this party equalizes our
nations and nationalities
despite violence between government
forces and local insurgent groups in
several parts of aromia state
officials in the prime minister's home
village of bashasha
say there's nothing to worry about
we have organized the community leaders
or village leaders
and they are ready to keep the
environment peaceful we are ready to
protect the area from any conflict
abby's birthplace might guarantee safe
pools but in other parts of aromia
unrest is rampant
oromo armed groups actively contest the
holding of elections
claiming they're undemocratic and that
the current government is illegitimate
the two main opposition parties in
oromia decided to withdraw
their main leaders are behind bars this
young man is too scared to speak
publicly
fearing reprisal from authorities he was
among many who celebrated when the prime
minister came to power but he's lost
trust in the government
we are hearing about the loss of so many
lives
and the numbers are increasing day by
day as we come closer to the election
time
we are still hearing that people are
being killed
those who are in prison as well as
opposition parties should be set free
there should be a discussion with the
people and there should be a national
dialogue
i ask the government to do this in a
peaceful way without any loss of life
especially in western aromia clashes
between the oromo liberation army
and federal forces pose a major threat
to the elections
inter-ethnic violence has also left
hundreds dead
and thousands displaced as a consequence
several constituencies will not be able
to vote on june 21st
the international community has warned
of electoral violence
to reduce the risks the european union
held trainings such as this one
to provide tools for peace building
targeting women
youth groups and traditional leaders the
civil society can play
a great role in terms of preventing
managing and mitigating
electoral violence that leadership helps
to play active role in the negotiation
process
they play active role in bringing
different parties
together for building peace that
role also helps them
to have a mediation role through the
vote abby ahmed seeks to establish his
political legitimacy
but the prime minister is facing various
challenges including the conflict in
tigray
for which he's facing mounting pressure
at home
and abroad and for more on ethiopia's
election we've invited ademobe onto the
program he is
an advisor and and an analyst on
democracy in africa he specializes
on ethiopia welcome to dw news africa
doctor
baby we've heard that this election
could chart a new path for ethiopia in
fact prime minister abhi ahmed said
it could build or break the country help
us understand
what is at stake in this election
thank you very much for the invitation
so the the elections are
critical in a sense because the the last
time ethiopia had elections was in 2015
and at that particular time it was a
dominant
uh ruling party that won all the seats
and since then abi ahmed came to power
in april 2018
and he has also established a new
political party
um so this is the first time that abby
ahmed as an individual
and his ruling prosperity party other
party will face the voters
so in that sense it's critical uh for
the ruling party more
more than uh for for the country um in
terms of the
the larger people i think uh i don't
expect the elections to be a mech or
break moment
partly because the two places where the
ruling party could have faced
a tremendous challenge have been
have been affected by different disputes
one in tiguay because of the conflict
and secondly in oromia region which is
the largest region in ethiopia
because of boycotts from the elections
we'll talk more about that in a moment
dr baby
but i first want to ask you how much
does prime minister abi ahmed
need to win this election how much does
he need to be able to say
i have a mandate from the people
um well so he i think that there's
really no question that he's going to
win the elections uh perhaps the key
the question is by how much and he needs
the victory
partly because currently his mandate
originates from
an election in 2015 which which was a
farce
so he wants a renewed mandate
and these elections can provide him that
claim although as i said
there's a lot of issues around the
elections that may affect that claim
dr baby doubts have been raised by the
international community
about the credibility of this election
is this going to be a free and fair poll
um that that certainly was the
expectation when abi yahama came to
power in 2018
and also in 2020 when the elections were
initially supposed to happen
but a lot has happened since then there
is an ongoing conflict in the tiguay
region of
ethiopia and the elections in oromia
have been boycotted by the key
opposition groups
and even in other parts of the country
opposition parties
have faced challenges in terms of
presenting their candidates
and operating freely and fairly so i
think
free and fairness will be a high a high
standard
but if you compare the elections with
the ones that happened
in the past and that they provide quite
a low bar uh we can say that these
elections
would would be would be better perhaps i
think that
the biggest um the biggest beneficiary
if i can say of these elections would be
the electoral board which has developed
tremendous experience
and tremendous expertise in terms of
managing
elections and i think that experience
will be relevant
going forward dr bebe
you you've said that from what you're
saying
an election isn't going to fix the
country what does ethiopia need
uh going on your assumption that prime
minister abby ahmed will win this
election
what's he got to do uh to tackle some of
the
the most pressing issues in the country
and of course that will be the tensions
in the different regions seeking
autonomy
or romeo for one that you have been
referring
um no you you're right i think the
elections uh they
you know you can argue they are
necessary we can argue uh if they are
desirable
but one thing that we know is that the
elections are not going to solve
the the problems of power balance the
political divisions that we see in the
country
they cannot and they are not meant to to
solve those issues
um so if we can uh if the prime minister
abi ahmed
gets a new mandate and a new new claim
of legitimacy
he would do well to engage one in in
rebuilding confidence
because i think that the level of trust
and confidence has suffered
partly as a result of the circumstance
under which the elections are being held
and partly because of other reasons so i
think he would do well to first rebuild
confidence
and then engage in a comprehensive
dialogue to resolve
the key issues between himself
and some opposition parties as well as
those that are outside of the the
electoral competition at the moment
so i think dialogue would be critical
and without it
the elections may not have made much
difference
all right dr adam thank you for your
insight
thank you very much